what's up fool what's up fool podcast
walk up to the wolf so full podcast we
got Rodrigo torrents right here what's
up and Marty moderno co-host of the year
over here what's opera I would through
my extra co-hosts give me an extra month
what's up people we have a lot of things
to say
first of all arm Martin we're not here
because he's promoting his show coming
up way more tea sure January 4th
generally for 2020 so that's for 21 for
20 over in New Jersey Dave Morris Plains
New Jersey and then the 31st for New
Year's
dupa this is right around the corner
Felipe 31st for New Year's I'll be in
Iowa at the First Avenue Club and the
second I will be in Chicago and you can
get all those tickets at Martine Moreno
calm we're gonna be able three well I'm
gonna be at Laguna tonight Laguna
tonight Boyle Heights yeah that's right
I'm gonna be there to Paramount Theater
yeah yeah the guy from Alex cutter boy
from New York is gonna be there he just
posted it up the vegan guy I don't think
that's his name say I get on the beacon
chicks in New York you know they're dumb
they don't know Cameron Boyce ounds good
I got a mola mola what so forth that's a
big new laser gentlemen some big-ass
news ladies and gentlemen this Friday at
10:00 a.m. if you're listening on Friday
or you're watching this live on YouTube
right now
what's up we're here at 10:00 a.m.
tickets will go on sale for the
observatory theater Netflix special
filming that's gonna take place January
27 to shows one in English one in
English
two shows in English a Netflix taping in
Santa Ana California in English is all
you know no January 28 the next day of
doing two spanish shows in the same spot
so the first night is - english shows
the second night - spanish shows limited
seating for the spanish show community
no no no how many people are gonna show
up let me get to you for all the shows
yes because they're only i think i'm
crazy yeah and then the Spanish ones
have tables so I think there's less than
200 or maybe 250th Asian what's up fool
tickets on sale Friday at Felipe
world.com / tour Philly with the world
that counts last tour Napa California
that's this Saturday okay back to
business
this Saturday Napa California it's
Friday this Friday November 22nd at the
Uptown Theater Seattle Washington this
Saturday November 23rd at the Neptune
theatre Pittsburgh Pennsylvania November
29th through December 1st Pittsburgh
improv man anybody out there man who's
planning on going to a Steeler game and
if you ain't doing [ __ ] on Saturday bra
girl with tickets Grand Prairie Texas
grab / Airy December 6 at the Verizon
theater with Marlon Wayans
DeRay Davis cocoa brown faizon love
Plus me Felipe Esparza mixing it up over
there making a show making sure that
show a diverse by throwing me on there
Portland Oregon December 13 that's my
wedding anniversary actually ladies and
gentlemen I will be there performing at
the revolution haw Revolution Hall I've
been there many times and many more
dates check them out at philippi
WorldCom no Napa everyone who's gonna be
on this show it's gonna be the return of
Martin Rizal and Rachel Wolf's in
Seattle we have stoner Rob that's right
so I know was a pound of weed I don't
know why they can show that with a pound
we're really gonna smoke that much
that's my weed you always wonder man
when people say they're gonna smoke you
are and they show up like with too much
do I want to hear an hour yeah that's a
lot of pot bro I mean if it's good but
you don't need a pound of meat you eat
it was no powerful gooey don't
congratulations bro Spanish and English
Robert Rogers I didn't even know it's
been that long but I got that I know I
got that you know your what you did last
year on Facebook and um
I saw that I opened up for Mexican
comedian San Diego I was one of her
openers I forgot her name but I got it
right here
I remember that lady who have a recovery
from cancer she was funny man like Raul
a rookie bro last year bro like Achilles
is covered on property was all smashed
was English and Spanish
haha Spanglish Spanglish all show bro
here are noche
we don't homeless what's up fools yeah
thank you for the congratulations is
that the first time anybody's done
Spanish and English and a special deals
up yo I don't know no no no we don't
know we think so I think so bro I mean I
have out of anybody I think it's yeah
and I think it's the first Spanish
special from an American comic you know
what I mean like all recorded one but I
anyway Paul Rodriguez and in Puerto Rico
and his praise be Oh years ago years ago
and there was those a guide a comedian
but he never did I think he did a
half-hour Comedy Central special but he
never did in Spanish even though he does
Spanish comedy bill Santiago I remember
that name Mary had that word joke up
here to heat or like kind of like Latino
sign foot up there hear a joke he was
very sarcastic he goes he would have a
joke way stay out and he liked Dino's
over there none and then why boy was
they think God and you know thank God
thank God it's funny I was talking to
Larry bubbles Brown uh-huh any charity
stories you know I don't want to talk
bad about him but you know there bubbles
his brother yeah he showed up what turn
ahead lighten up Nora's gonna wait
you're pregnant never themer Tommy baby
a cash so a year ago you started now
you're recording a freaking special
that's why I'm badass well it took a
long time but I heard that I have I had
the help of the fearless crew I've had
to help over three go you know living
you know Spanish word in there Martin oh
well from Tijuana mango from TJ that
food transcribed the whole thing in
Spanish my host said one time or a
couple of times well he did like you
knew what you were already saying and
you know what I'm saying like fix a few
things here and there and yeah the
hardest part was to take bro to think in
Spanish today we had the I had like some
jokes I were really with translator boat
and who they were funny but then some
that just did not play man like play on
words and burns mm-hmm but the Tubbataha
body no abuse and all that everything
was abuse kill the Spanish bro
nobody talked about child abuse talk
about feelings in Spanish so I'll talk
about that and healing it resonates with
the audience hey you know it's a it's a
brand new thing out there there's not a
whole lot about those out there doing it
so congratulations you've been doing
Spanish comedy as well my teen right uh
yeah I've been trying it a little
Spanish here in there bro I've been you
know working with Peter Louisa you guys
know people Sunday we were sure we did a
show with him too well we're gonna do a
show with him a victory I'm doing I'm
doing something with him and put us
fires out in Northern California
December 22nd actually a Mexican
comedian be having some wild names huh
when we show them a wrestling match oh
yeah oh let the do Carlos but I thought
I was a big ol I also grow my ass he's
got a whole clown suit on chupitos dude
I saw this dude like literally like
everybody Mexican like a lyric label
they Larry the Cable Guy temper coming a
lot of characters you're evolving at
this point yeah but the ones that are
evolving are blowing up the ones that
are doing more of a monologue are
blowing up yeah 100%
story's not but was it Carlos to a
character Misaki walks on the street
like that's chair I have you seen a fool
dr. glasses now they're bearable oh my
god what I love about you bro is you do
not censor dick bro you're doing movies
with no glasses or no glasses off no
give no he didn't care of it the goddess
sounds [ __ ] nature a burro
Thank You Luna he walks around with
little tiny Cubs silently milking goats
blood over a bridge where did you see in
space cuz I've never be anywhere whoa
it's out there it's out there underlip
inches in c1 Oliver ish
hey I'm not wobbly there but oh hi I
embraced my found a racy bro well we
will Tijuana man alive man everybody
tells about we had good tacos here late
we got a good talk with here Mexico and
Nora and here United States rosary oh
man and I got Hawaii to go to the
[ __ ] taco shop bro your but your
being not watching me see how good it
was how good I was not looking down the
streets and he was hoping missing here
and then out then i pair boo showed up
with big old boobs australia dog-faced
mother here man I'm not pretty either
but I feel sexy as [ __ ] lately I don't
know what it is I don't know what the
hell it is I just know sexy damn yeah
I'd wear glasses to home at are there a
picture of a bookie without a beard yeah
man they won't take you seriously that
that would that face dawg would I go
with a classy especially coming out
those joke with no like auto in your
consciousness you know
now I'll throw in your conscience for
real dog you gotta find a niche like me
I got the long hair bro right I got the
long hair I got the wildness you got
weird me but I know that have to be a
character Larry Larry the Cable Guy
mm-hmm something that makes you stand
out to be memorable I mean when I first
started comedy I had a [ __ ] fade and
a leather jacket which every poncho and
the razor point but you know but what's
crazy is that everybody and their mother
had a fade and a leather jacket you just
blend in and you look like every other
[ __ ] out there you know that's
why when when Gabe started using the
Hawaiian shirt
that [ __ ] pop when you started growing
your hair that [ __ ] pop I screw my
[ __ ] hair and now people [ __ ] like
a that's [ __ ] didn't you Martine right
there the if you just blend
with the whole [ __ ] crowd you just
can look alike like this bottle right
here with the leather jacket and a fake
[Laughter]
leather jacket everybody look like they
killed 10 cows for all the [ __ ]
comics that showed up how about when a
Bernardo coumadin Bernardo him in a
lady's shoulder with leather jacket and
other hats Bernardo the Puerto Rican
Bernardo yeah
God what's he up to bro he was working
at the brain province oh [ __ ] get for
him get on cars I think he was in
Pasadena at some dealership so him and
his lady brother showed up like like
what's his name Big Daddy Kane I put
another jacket on hooter when he was
1200 shut out to myself without people
sorry about last week man we didn't have
no podcast man my daughter flew in from
Sweden and she's been hanging out for
two weeks I got to meet her and my
grandson bro so we were all hanging out
if I run into [ __ ] Joker bro
the last merch guy for [ __ ] a lot of
rock I go outside to see him bro then he
was just I was so excited I was looking
at him like he was like a relic bro like
people talk about you know slaughter and
it you see him there bro he look like
he's not ready to be slaughtered bro
Cheesecake Factory where was that
Gladstone's no what was it yard house
man yeah he was just like this guy out
of out of place there with all these
suburban people and he was the closest I
had to a brother growing up bro like
when I was a teenager no no Willie bro
we I'm saying growing up homie I mean I
I'm a bully when I was [ __ ] a stop
boludo brawls [ __ ] 30-something but
but yeah hisui stoker dude freaking went
to high school together I remember the
first time we went to the mall I'm all
fold me to the side bro we took the bus
out to the mall and he pulled me to the
side and we didn't know each other that
was chocolate
that's what he said he goes they bro you
know they have cameras here right and
I'm like what are you talking about he
goes yeah they'd like whatever you do
they'll see you and I'm like why are you
telling me this he goes well just in
case you want to steal something they'll
probably catch us like a morphic I don't
steal and he's like well I don't know I
just had to make sure cuz I don't want
to get [ __ ] busted I'm like this
mother [ __ ] give you up that was the
first time we hung out man he was [ __ ]
he was always the guy that did the right
thing you know he like he could actually
he's a teacher he had every opportunity
to be a [ __ ] but out of everybody he
had to [ __ ] more together than everybody
graduated on time you know did his
[ __ ] homework and never went to the
ditching parties [ __ ] comedy troupe
right it was the good guy yeah we we
used to do scheduling we used to do
[ __ ] sketches bro like [ __ ] like
we just you still okay we still have a a
camera like you remember those big-ass
[ __ ] cameras you put on your on your
shoulder and and like and you do the
video it had the VHS tape and like a
big-ass camcorder my little brother oh
[ __ ] to the Christmas party oh and we
used to record [ __ ] [ __ ] bro would
you suggest two sketches we'd pretend
more like [ __ ] immigrants from Cuba
stuck in a [ __ ] refugee center we'd
[ __ ] pretend more [ __ ] I played a
gay barber or so stereotypical and
[ __ ] and just just complete like [ __ ]
that would get me protested if it came
out you know what I'm saying just like
over-the-top crazy [ __ ] he was want a
love you know he was playing a character
named want a because he had a glove and
he called it want a it's just [ __ ]
stupid as your performance in my [ __ ]
living room
[Laughter]
she's act like mrs. flagon
Mia pretty much over here to watch this
[ __ ] comedy vessel for the Joker Joker
okay before I ever before I did comedy
bright that all that we did freakin I
you know what I just wanted to do like I
thought I was funny and my homie had a
camera and I'm like hey [ __ ] it let's
start filming [ __ ] bro and we just
started [ __ ] filming [ __ ] who gave
him the name Joker uh dude he was joking
when I met him I'm guessing [ __ ] his
homies did you know how you doing bro
medium yeah yeah psychic medium yeah you
do stand-up comedy - yeah not really I
mean I've done stuff with actually good
friend of yours with moment Rodriguez
and stuff like that so we did the what
he call it the break into a show but
yeah I do a bunch of shows and stuff
like that and so we're planning to kind
of do something differently about like
going to the improv and doing comedy
because most the time what I do I talk
to the dead for a living that's like to
show you contact a lot of comedy shows
you know there's your stand-up stand-up
comedian they know that his magicians
you know who do stand-up
there's also hypnotist right yes there's
a lot of him and it mentioned it yet but
then also there's a coop that comedian
lady that we brought here
she's Karen ran'tao ski she does she
reads tarot cards she does psychic
readings yeah and she she she does not
ghost hunting but she does like objects
oh yeah psychometry yeah and she'll find
us the story behind it basically and
she'll you know when I first started
doing stand-up comedy before I'm Willy
and the devil
Jeff Garcia where they were doing wild
coyotes it was Ron some gay dude and he
was wack right
and he's only booked him comedian from
the comedy store that were like white
and one of the ladies I was there she
was funny but she was she was like a
psychic reader but she did numbers ok
numerology and numerology like you think
about number and then she like we're
like wow they also do like they tell you
stuff about like oh you're born right
the number the month that you were born
and all that yeah so you have like a
personality number and then you have a
master number and then an add to number
all these numbers represent certain
things so when you break those down it
kind of shows like your soul cycle where
you're at so it's interesting because
like I wasn't a big believer in psychics
or mediums at all whatsoever like I
wasn't you know I was watching certain
television shows like Sally Jessy
Raphael Jenny Jones and all these
psychics that were on television I'm
like what a crock of [ __ ] these people
are like telling what's good and what to
do and that's where I really thought
yeah because I don't really believe in
it Mike I come with a healthy skepticism
and I really don't want to believe
everything I like to debunk things or
trying to analyze things of like are
people actually really doing this or
they're kind of like reading off
emotions are they reading off like
things that they already know about
people is a cute card yeah so all that
stuff was like you know it how do I like
make the trust there so about mean the
trust in myself but you have seen the
information that I was receiving so if
it was from spirit it was something
psychically around so his personal life
I would just tell like it is my journey
started in a very unique way like I
didn't see spirit I knew fill spirit
again I was about researching and trying
to develop this and trying to technical
for you though yeah feeling oh yeah
absolutely and it's a feeling now
because it's about like what I sense or
what I pick up a part on a person so
when I do large audience events I can go
like hey lady and you know 50th row
stand up I got like your brother here
who's passed over like it's that
specific it's not just that's like very
specific yeah it's actually like say
they pass with a triple bypass and they
then and I like you know but that will
be a or fake stuff what do you ever
heard of amazing Jonathan yes he goes
out there there's a lady rat the your
mom stand up oh you graduated in 1985
here a brother named Jonathan hey the
gentleman that's my sister
[Laughter]
I mean you have to have a sense of humor
with this work I mean it's like it's
it's humor are you writing stuffins in
between yeah you know it like I don't do
a lot of stand-up but you know it's
something that people want me to bring
onto because I think it's more humorous
with the work that I do because our
loved ones will bring humorous things
personal things that are very
embarrassing and I will talk about it
live on a show or do you know whatever
comes you guys do have a reputation for
being charlatans no so the lobby so
there's a lot of skepticism that goes
with that goes with it right absolutely
and so it's it's some some people it's
hard for people to take you seriously oh
absolutely
now now when you say you communicate
with people that are passed over when
they talk to you is it like they're
saying something to you and then they
say hey say this to the person or
because I know a lot of people that are
mediums will sit there and be like
freaking like they'll start talking
almost like they'll start talking
through them they become the vessel that
the channel yeah that's a great example
of so what do you do so I I do more than
mediumship which is mental mediumship so
I will pick up the information that's
coming through so when I'm communicating
with the spirit I actually hear my own
thought and they show me symbols and
everything's out of my from reference so
if I see say you know an Apple could be
someone that works of computers could be
sewing that loves you know someone whose
religion Adam and Eve so it's my friend
reference or - it can be the person's
you know loved ones loved baking apple
pie so I can totally misinterpret the
information but I'll deliver that
information but also I will feel the
information of how they passed over so
they're shot in the head I will feel
pressure to my head it was a triple bite
as well I would feel like I was asked
something in my chest if it was
emphysema filled water in my lungs so
there's weird feelings that I'll get
that my body I have to resonate with
those feelings that's coming through
that's intense because I I have I have
old albums of preachers from back in the
1960s and things where they're like
performing well and it's a performance
in front of like thousands of people and
do to be like as I was walking here
today the Spirit of the Lord came to me
and he came on my shoulder and he said
to me there's somebody here there's
somebody here near his name starts with
the letter the letter F and he's named
after a country and your name is your
name is France and then somebody will be
like yeah he was like yeah
[Laughter]
and so then and this guy was super super
specific to the point where it was like
almost ridiculous right
there's no way in [ __ ] this is happening
with his degree and and so it's like
super over the [ __ ] top right you
know what I mean like if you listen to
it today back then back in the day it
was probably amazing right now when you
look at it with with freaking 20:19 eyes
or listen with 20:19 ears rather you're
not sure is this [ __ ] monkey serious
right like this is [ __ ] ridiculous on
the phone and then at the end it's like
[ __ ] send a hundred dollars this is
the $900 of [ __ ] week dude that was
[ __ ] way more than minimum wage but
people did it people sent in peter
Popoff [ __ ] bags of spring water my
redneck people in poor black we were
talking about Oh once I bought that
water the next day I woke up and it was
[Laughter]
you know you know the next one's gonna
be freakin Kanye how many times have you
been correct though
I don't know because I deliver all the
information because I always believe I
don't mind being wrong because as long
as I deliver the information it's
deliver the right way so again I may
misinterpret something I may say hey you
know today that you spilled spaghetti on
your lap and you go like no is actually
oatmeal some people see that as being
wrong but I mean so it just depends on
how you interpret that information or
how it resonates with you but I I don't
think that I wrong I do really believe
that I can misinterpret so I'm gonna be
the first to admit and I say that's that
all my events all interviews because I
will never be a hundred percent right
none of us will be but we will have
these gut feelings where we feel things
and sense things and just like
law-enforcement officials like they have
a gut feeling or this hunch about a
certain case it's the same thing that I
do but I just work in a different way
yeah did Epstein kill himself remember
that guy from they were to their hand
that chubby guy somebody somebody with
your [ __ ] sculptures that would make
a summons beetlejuice
he came out and he fought with everybody
was there well hurt some of the most
right you know like something that will
hurt you the most and she [ __ ] up that
lady's sculpture right because she loved
the sculpture then together was a the
medium he put him in plaid ya know
Beetlejuice is another great movie ghost
like all these are very similar to what
we do but if I could say like the best
movie that kind of demonstrates
mediumship or or this work is is go
especially that was wet in the late
early 90s
[ __ ] yeah scary about that maybe Liz
Lemon scared about that movie with me
when they kill you and then those black
spirits kind of what are those
[ __ ] right or like you know the
bad energy all that do they get you in
you're in purgatory you know I think
some of us are taught to believe in you
know
Boh purgatory also I don't believe in
that you know as either dead as a
doorknob yeah you know why purgatory
existed what okay so that they could
export families that had money enough
once a year and to get them out of here
some masses for then he'll be able to
get his [ __ ] yeah it's like yeah now let
me ask you this are you did you grow up
Catholic and I'm saying oh sure
okay sure with the Catholics anybody if
when you got dabble into the freaking
medium thing cross across was that
blasphemy like is your family like a
peach II would hope that wrong you know
that's funny that you say that because
they look like they they weren't big
believers at all my parents were devout
Catholics they went to Catholic school
the whole nine yards same thing with me
you know I started growing up and I
started having a different understanding
of my Catholicism you know I didn't know
I did not know if like this is something
I was gonna follow is like because I
always felt there was some sort of
feelings or intuitions I was picking up
around certain things and I would know
certain things about like say you know
caller ID I would joke around with my
family like I was caller ID back then it
was about people who would call I would
say hello so and so that's so and so
that's calling and it could be someone
that we haven't talked to in years or
whatever and sure enough it's that
person but for my parents they would say
like I don't believe in it I don't talk
about this then my parents would never
talk about like what I did for a living
they would say my son's a consultant
he's a consultant a consultant they
would never say that and until like I
really don't have a son ya know see
people lookin token for what you know
it's like dead people so when did you
start having feelings or thinking that
just because you said you watched other
people on TV was that after knowing you
had some gift did you get a feeling and
then start looking into it like had it
at all it was more curiosity and
skepticism alone that really kind of
brought me on this path because I really
want to understand what I was picking up
in what I was feeling like was it just
like you know coincidences where there
was just guessing this information
that's coming through was I actually
picking up information so for me and it
just coming to you yeah and I did not
strangers even yeah walk around oh yeah
I remember one story specifically I
think I was what maybe 13 14 years old
and I remember waiting and waiting line
at Utley you know fast food joint and
saying like oh my god I see this lady's
father standing like right next to her
right behind her this and that I'm like
do I really tell this lady this and I
really tapped on her like I she waited
in line I said hey I have your dad's
here and he's tell me this in this and
and he passed away oh yeah I got it
Wow and came down you could walk up to
somebody man it's someone like you don't
know him but someone like Adam Murray
bro walks up to somebody like that throw
the ball hey dawg yeah and you know she
came back she thanked me because she
goes I just lost my dad like a month ago
so it was a moment for her to recognize
there's something that happened she
didn't know me and above it you know so
when stuff like that happens yeah I
think 13 14 years old you know so I
right around that age frame so the way
Mike were started per se or my path was
I actually started working with Tell
cards from sixth grade to eighth grade
and started reading around that's a dong
oh yeah and you know what's that about
12 13 yes yeah so during that time frame
I was reading people do around my junior
high school I was telling them like what
I saw what I thought who was coming
through here doing it for those tickets
yeah yeah and so for me I was just like
oh maybe I'm a good guess or maybe I'm
just guessing this information but weeks
later a month later I said oh my god
like this person had this situation or
has this health issues or this is
happening and so for me I'm like I don't
think anything of it and then my
mediumship happened when I was a
freshman in high school my high school
teacher who's a recognized medium in her
own right and works with very well-known
people and she told me at the ability to
communicate with other side I did not
know that I knew I was able to see auras
in colors and feel things off people but
I did not know I was able to talk to
that per se so I thought it was just
things that were happening so I
developed my abilities on my own and
working with them I didn't take any
classes or and I didn't go to a school
like every pot or whatever but for me at
age 19 I was signed
with a pretty big station and my career
took off West Asia Coast 103.5 look
that's yeah I love songs gonna love some
coast I was do you
yeah I was on there for three and a half
years you know the best part about that
show bro
I'm afraid it's BS bro when they would
let this right now we Barbara coasting
in Santa Barbara right now might send a
message to Mike whose coast yes to
[Laughter]
midnight and how do you every day every
Sunday was a Sunday night special show
from 7:00 to midnight went to the show
right now but man did some good shows
they come on on Sunday radio we really
look out for them oh yeah for sure oh
that one guy that our bell or the name
yeah well our Bell is we know talking
about here one via rel hmm and what time
while I was driving from Lake Tahoe with
Paul Rodriguez and he started playing we
yeah yeah show with the weird characters
he would do and callers and that was all
fake people loved it but I think people
are always so curious and curious yeah
and they wanted to like aired well I
don't like it's nothing to be afraid of
because I think if we grew up in a
Catholic background or religious
background we have that fear of like
it's a devil's work it's taboo things on
nature and once my parents realize that
this is like not a phase I've been doing
this for well over 16 years I go
this is not a phase this is like what I
do for living my parents realize like
you know oh my son's a medium he's a
psychic now and I've been very
successful with what I had done in my
background with my work and I'm very
blessed because I think you know I came
from a small suburban city in Hacienda
Heights California didn't come from much
my family that family didn't come from
much and I stayed grounded from that
because I really believe if you connect
kind of connect with people or the
audience they can recognize that but
also see some comfort in that as well so
again things were blessed because my
background really I wanted to be a
firefighter I wanted to work in law
enforcement but my career took off with
that one radio station again I didn't
have a website a phone number or
anything because I didn't want to do
this for a living however when you
started in a Coast in nineteen and a
half went to Kay big kiss offend hot 92
and then we heard you were seen you do
this before what what made them bring
you on so an email was submitted to one
of the producers to coast I do not
sympathy mail because again I wasn't I
didn't want to do this I was going in
Rio Hondo college and taking my classes
to be a firefighter yeah it's a bit a
big program lately extensive so I was
doing that and then they producer end up
calling me my cell number I'm like okay
what's what's this guy I thought this is
a joke and I hung up and I did not reply
to it I thought this seemed like I don't
know if I can cuts on here but I super
nori over here
[Laughter]
keeping up with a show man how do you
get a feeling from somebody who you're
not connecting with other than hearing
their voice
right so the everything's based upon
energy everything has energy a table mic
everything vibrates and energy it's like
help people who are like deaf or blind
they can actually hear sound feel like
fear sound feel or see things in a
different way it's the same thing but
just in a different vibration so when
someone speaking to me over the phone
many years ago the way it worked for me
is I have actually would see eye color
so I would have my eyes closed when
someone's talking that color would
resonate okay if I saw red I know
they're a very grounded person I've saw
orange or represent they're very
ambitious yellow would represent their
colors come from some from my from
reference oh yeah what it means to me
and if every will have different
references what these colors represent
but that would kind of that's just over
time and experience oh yeah okay that
time I did not know what I was receiving
or picking up or sensing things that
nature and I had to interpret that over
years it took I'm still building my
dictionary over 16 years so things will
always be the same and things may not be
the same thing and I may totally be
wrong and misinterpret but I always
would deliver that information but for
me the producers brought me into that
show in the studio and when I went there
they said like oh who's the like where's
the medium at they saw me like this
little you know shaved head and little
goatee and this and that and who's this
kid you know that's gonna read four
people and they helped me do like six
readings on spot just to make sure like
everything's legit everything's culture
that they have people from Kansas
wherever did the readings and from there
on they said oh we'll see you next week
and I was signed on for three hours now
are you stoked do you go to church now
you renew this I don't I'm not a
practicing Catholic so I would say that
but I still believe in God I still
believe in a higher power I still do
pray or meditation in all my readings
all my you know shows that I do it so
it's engrained into my work for sure but
I don't practice it where I go to church
but I practice it in my own way
basically yeah now if somebody comes to
you and says hey man I lost a loved one
I want to reach out did you find can you
find them or do they come to you I
really don't want to know who my clients
wanna connect with so I don't do any way
bookings I don't do any of that stuff
you know most of stuff I it's all
through into the office so that's one
cold yeah it's because I don't want
because I really believe if I know
anything about someone's loved one like
they say oh I wanted to uncle Joey
passed away
that's right yeah it takes away yeah
because if you know that information
then that you'll read on the job for the
medium so there's nothing for me to
really do be since you already validate
all that stuff so maybe that's not the
person who's coming through the
strongest maybe the only yes that is for
sure like people want to hear from you
know when they when people go to my
audience events like that you know
there's large crowds intimate groups
that I do and people have that VIP
person they want to hear from absolutely
positively and that moment happens where
I connect with maybe their dad instead
of their mother or their mothers to
their father because whatever that
relationship was either you know
whatever was they don't want to hear for
that person but I like they need to come
through because there's a message that
they need to get across that they still
need to heal from physically that they
have a louder stuff to go through so
it's interesting yeah yeah how did you
know like to reach them like for me it's
through meditation prayer chakras so
basically the way the energy works is
that once I turn on and meditate it open
up I just kind of do my thing and so
whoever's energies are strongest it kind
of works that way so kind of think of it
as like you know in a very funny way all
you guys are here today and I tell you
it as like mentally or maybe verbally
say my name at once
whoever's voice I hear first and
whoever's voice is strongest that's who
I connect with first and an audience
events and so kind of think of it that
way at any event and I get pulled that
person so I go hey you know anybody do
you ever like read somebody goes oh [ __ ]
man
oh yeah yeah that is like oh yeah
embarrassed
well sometimes I'll be giving a name
about a person who's in the audience I'm
like who's like like say Angela or
something and they're like no there's
not an Angela there's not this I go you
sure there's like an Angela Angie
there's something of realize oh my name
is Angela so they will form they'll file
here now it's November now the other
look there the bed just where a guy who
passed away right here bro look it we
have a Brody Stephens he passed away
now the other los muertos is that at
they were players like you here are
baseball
something like that do that supposedly
all the spirits come from the other side
to visit what is their truth to that
what do you know about that so there's
two things one's gonna be cultural once
it's gonna be depends how you grew up
and how you see that so if you're very
cultural very connected with that I
would say one that's a deep-rooted
connection
- if that's a very unique thing in our
work as media mystics or mediums is that
there's the what we call the veils thin
where it's easier for our loved ones to
communicate so if you really want to
communicate with your loved ones and
honor them if they love like drinking
milk you put out a milk for them or
their favorite dish or whatever it is
but there's a very harrowing prizes me
like I never believed in it kind of deal
don't but I remember you remember when
we were in Columbus and it was raining
real loud
real hard it would mean you Amanda we
were eating at that place they had
trivia under the television exactly what
you're talking and we met up these to
lay on the Navy one of the dominican
black lady and i see neither both
sergeants yes and then we burn it at the
Blue Martini ah yes then the black lady
was been into psychics
ah how she had a reading for me bro let
me tell you I know through the reading
okay she was she was on point right so
you still remember yeah she said you
have a daughter out there and I did she
was she's very little she was she loves
you yoshino the children she knows
you're out there push each other Mitch
you should know her out that you know
you're out there
she oh she knows she know you're out
there is what she's seeking for you in
what she loves you and he goes you know
I'm this close very strong you know put
a test-retest team at is trying it
together where you needed to talk to I
you that right now I don't know what was
going on you know but I see my daughter
a year later but right now we're close
but that's awesome well I didn't know
but I never told you later on she ran
back Oh
you know she saw me at the show she
loved the show so she must have found a
vibe that's too funny or he's crazy you
know something about him right now
well she did was just talking about
having one time when she knew yeah
often times you know what a wild guess
well I think it's a wild guess I think
it's either someone's vibrating
something it's very strongly about a
person so if you get that vibration I
will go up to someone and tell someone
like hey this is what I'm picking up
this one I'm getting I don't do that now
because it's gonna touch me I'm an
American yeah yeah there's ethics you
don't even when you do this work so you
have to be careful but there are people
that will go up to someone saying like
hey you know I see this or I sense this
or this is what you need to hear and
sometimes it's just that and they walk
away you never see them again because
that information something that you need
to hear or it's gonna help you evolve as
a person or grow as a family together
and I think that's an amazing thing that
happened for you so believer or not I
think it's a great experience that you
had that was super cool because I always
tell people have been back then I still
haven't met my daughter
why yeah you had only seen her yeah and
did you not have any connection so I
think there's some sort of universal
thing or synchronicity that was
happening here for you in a very
beautiful way that had to happen it was
a story about a tornado
doctor warning those are tornado warning
we were scared it's already real it will
we're a windy then on a southern hail oh
wow I think I will fire then I got real
bright then then it started raining real
hard then they were I was saying that
y'all better run it was extreme as well
the rate would call me sideways yeah I
was [ __ ] nuts now when when you hurt
like when people's when you started
communicating okay did it scare you
yes and no and seeing people standing
next to somebody like that that was more
scary to me yeah because like my first
experience honestly was my
great-grandfather
that's was standing at the end of my bed
I was still living at my parents at the
time obviously but I did not meet my
grateful grandfather I did not know what
he looked like but I remember time and
mom the next morning I said hey they you
know like there was a sky of toilet
experience my mom again wasn't a big
believer very Catholic and it was very
awkward to talk about this I said yeah
this guy had no aren't he didn't have
any arms he was missing his arms and
this was shattered the old Joe well
well no my great-grandfather lost both
arms he was a W amputee and lost both
arms and there's no way I would have
known that gnorga wasn't ever talked
about and so I described that and I was
talking about like his riding and my
grandfather had this most beautiful
riding he would write everything with
his mouth these letters and stuff like
that so and so my mom and her going to
my grandparents or to her parents house
and started researching going through
all those you know photos and things
that nature I'm like oh yeah and so my
mom freaked out but again there's
moments like that that happened that do
freaked me out like that because I
should have known that I had a friend
who died and I watched him die I was
there during his passing and we he saw
his grandfather that he hadn't seen in
20 25 years at the end of his bed right
he said he's standing right there yeah
it's a normal thing and that was the
house that his grandfather was in and
it's his grandmother he wanted to die in
his grandmother's house but his he said
he's right there and then I don't know
five minutes later he passed away
oftentimes people on the death bed they
will experience that they will say
they're going to seeing someone or
they're what someone or they see certain
loved ones that they haven't seen in
many many years or connect with with and
and he was a beautiful example because
they were there to greet them or
transition that when Sam Kinison died
the comedian and there by the drunk
driver they hit him they said that when
they were talking to him he was a way
out of it he kept saying I'm not ready
I'm not ready and then he smiled and
said I'm ready and he gone he was
talking about oh wow cuz I'm not ready
I'm not ready then other studies that
I'm ready and not was a Baptist minister
before him yeah that's great but so like
he must have like said I'm sorry for the
other photo shades there that moment or
something I've I'm just thinking of the
Catholic you know all right yeah I mean
there's something we go through is it
like a soul contract you know we go
through the soul contract or soul review
that we go through these issues when we
go through these things and maybe
there's things that he needed to make up
or needed a fix or whatever and he said
like I'm not ready or maybe he had to
make peace with himself before we
transition but you know the beautiful
thing often times a certain reason I've
done when someone died tragically like a
great example is like jenny rivera
you know when she passed over like her
body left the soul before impact there's
a perfect moment people and I didn't
know that just because there was a
moment of like not feeling that when you
read for these people you don't they
don't bring me the moment of impact it's
almost like their souls gone like it's
like a
/ of them already like out of that body
it's the best way to describe it because
typically I will talk about an event of
a passing so someone was shot I will
actually feel that pressure or stabbing
or whatever it is but certain times when
spirits don't talk about that where they
say they're so left or the left in that
moment it's kind of the oh [ __ ] moment
for me because that's I realized that
years ago and that's became kind of a
reference when people died in a very
tragic event and it's their way making
that validation showing that they do not
suffer they did not go through pain so
and I think it's only to help us the
physical people as well so it's very
much buddy i watch several people die
because well friends who died but also i
worked in a nursing home and so i saw a
lot of people die but you can see the
point at which their soul is gone if
it's one of those long deaths or your
wait you understanding their what
witnessing it you at some point you
realize oh that it's not that person
anymore you feel it you see it oh yeah
and that's so that's so a quick quick
death is what you're saying the soul
left already before the impact before
they die before the moment of death and
when that moment happens it's a
beautiful moment I remember a couple
moment there's a couple clients that
sent me photos over the years like old
Polaroids where they're taking photos
with their loved ones and you know
they're like last moment if they're
dying of cancer or whatever they're on
the bed the family's there and certain
photos show like a body like right above
over this gold white light right above
the body as a soil body is right above
that leaving that so for me it's kind of
evidence I don't can't see it's you know
evidence as a scientific point but it's
evidence for me as a spiritualist you
believe that there's something more than
this physical body because I do believe
that we evolve and grow after this I
don't think we're just dead in the
ground
I don't think that we're you know this
is just our physical realm because I
think this is just our high school when
we transition we go to college and we
learn we grow evolve and during the
lessons that we needed to fake so
someone was you know a murder and you
know or someone that took their own
lives they still have to take those
problems with them physically to the
other side because he don't learn from
those so there's some sort of car Matic
death they had to go through as well
that's all that's what that's a heavy
statement oh yeah I mean that's a very
very little statement like I say that
we're taking baggage to the other side
is freaking because you would figure
once you're done you're resting yeah you
know that's why a lot of them stir right
a lot of the souls that stir that's what
I've heard
like what happened to Chucky right
[Laughter]
hasn't had something resolved that's why
even like some of those like little kids
or like little and they started they
talk like a dog already they say a bunch
of crazy snake it's like another soul
into that little bunny yeah sure so
they've been here before
oh absolutely it's old enough to handle
the shine and I think we like kind of
open a receptivity that it's the same
thing but again it's just like it's a
heavy statement to say but it's it's
over the years where I've learned over
the years when you were a little kid do
you remember those time life books a
woman fifty miles away by the way she
feels a daughter jazz escape a fire yeah
decided not to get out of place to get a
plane all right coincidence I ever
spayed at the best joke a woman feel the
sharp pain while doing dishes came out
of the way her daughter's giving her
boyfriend a hand job the people who
don't believe like right here we have a
milkman that have you asked people some
psychics
you know the false one brother out there
no I appreciate there's a certain
questions and they get people you know
like like for example we're talking like
example before teleport television
before radio before all that how many
people were traveling for like because
everybody could make money they'd be
really fear the horse and carriage you
have a circus like you could entertain
you know just show up what a crystal
ball and then right I heard of these
people will show up ahead of time I
started to know the people in the sent
back and little notes but that's back
then no first well you should show up
yeah I just show up I show up either
like 10 minutes before event or like
right beforehand I don't know what
helping you I'm helping me out we do
comedians brother walk coach what we're
doing at a corporate gig they go abroad
make fun of sam neill over there the
fireman his wife left ya gonna real two
times
that's what you can make funny
absolutely make fun of him yeah you know
all that [ __ ] [ __ ] up no but you know
that is something that was that's still
very common that people still feel that
it still happened to this day like they
go oh these people are planted in the
audience or the tell people what to say
I mean there's many mediums but that man
had to meet him bro I think people
believe it because they were here yeah
and you and she they're here like Sally
from Charlie Brown same thing you know
all these BM at you know go under fire
because of people's belief or skepticism
and you know James Randi with a little
boy to a little white boy no Tyler Henry
title Hollywood medium yeah so you know
you have all the people and people are
always gonna criticize and for me like
you know when I reap for people that are
entertainment sometimes you know I don't
really know who they are because either
like I don't know the background or
whatever and there's people that I'm
like I feel like that I know too much
about them and I won't read them because
like it's too much so it's I don't
really want to be like a celebrity
medium but I've been fortunate to read
for a lot of musicians a lot of people
and that's how a lot of things happen
with me because you know have you ever
[ __ ] took mushrooms and did a real OD
bro how have a question could you say
you went deep right when you meditate
you goin I don't when I was in rehab
there was a guy named Jose Quintana and
it was chewy
he stayed with him for sup for like
10-15 years okay got out for 60 days and
then there another chance but he told me
that the second time you went in there
and you say had a better time in those
ten years because started meditating he
said you got so so deep he said that he
left the prison for a month
Oh came back after all abstraction yeah
had about experience to put yeah man
yeah can you do that could you can you
like beer so institutionalized use a
robot now yes and no I think meditation
is one of those those abilities that we
see bro it's what you gotta think you're
sending yourself your clothes your mind
your robberies came back yard and give
her money yeah
here the first time okay primo movie
Primo levy wrote up well he was an
Italian custody Holocaust survivor who
wrote a book of his experience and in
the in the camps he talked about doing
that as a survival mechanism not a strop
he didn't call it astral projection but
he was meditating to imagine himself
somewhere on that place outside of where
they were and that's the only thing that
kept him going yeah because we have to
do that in certain points in our lives
when things are so bad we kind of focus
on the positive it's like you know
what's the law of attraction you know
the secret is a great you know book
about it that talks about it you know
that shares about the movie but it's
been around for years and people been
doing it for years but not many who are
receptive or understand the process of
how it all works but if we kind of can
get back to that point and really kind
of detach and hear from those moments we
really like we realize that there's
something more out there you know that's
super cool one of the next show we need
to be doing is you know I actually took
my last show last week so I did my last
show last week it was sold out but I'm
gonna start launching my tour in January
and you know people can find that on my
website of a Jaber or calm or social
media any of that stuff that's lower
AJ Barrera yeah any day for a ride
doctor yeah but yeah but that's how
things happen but I do like two shows a
month and you know they're smaller or
large events but it's really interesting
you know people were like who are like
that's not desperate but you know they
never heard or they only need like
closure do they recall you oh yeah you
know you go to their pad and you talk to
them yeah I mean I have to like feel
thankful afterward for sure I mean like
I don't do house calls I am but I yeah
yeah but I do have two offices doctor's
talk to you dad though right but people
do come come for a reading and that
could be from losing a child you know a
feeling you know close you know sibling
or a mother or father and you know they
walk away having that peace and healing
and I don't think we ever really get
closure she thinks because I think
closures that were ending a chapter were
ending something so I do believe we got
healing what we evolved from that
experience in oftentimes people will
realize that you know what I'd like to
see bro
you talk to Rosie O'Donnell I know Rosie
O'Donnell she was a Howard Stern and she
talked about her story she talked about
how when her mom died they just kept it
from her she was too little I did
see I hid it from her they never told
her never got that close you see let's
go to march into that they ate her
probably half of their family for a
while so she never got that man I wonder
like her own she believes it but if you
ever ever could talk to her bro maybe
you could help her talk to her mom
absolutely but that's something that
that [ __ ] up to do to a kid right
because know she done it
the neighbor told her my mommy said [ __ ]
I [ __ ] don't know David David for his
wife yeah really
could you know their story right now the
dad kept the mom from them
yeah I can't say too I my wife's like
well we love much about it but he said
Howard Stern yeah I don't know the John
Carradine city on Howard Stern right
Robert Robert Carradine yeah doctor
borrow the dad kept the mom from there
yeah there was a lot around that a lot
of girls around that let me ask you this
what about like the the Ouija board okay
[Music]
yeah so like that's oh is that a
standard for medium yeah I mean you have
to think about like spirituality
movement that a spiritual moving that
happened in the 1800's the early 1800
that's what the Ouija board chip sees
yeah there was actually three I can't
say specifically three sisters with
three sisters the Fox sisters were the
one that created it Catholic I don't
know if they were Catholic but they were
started a spiritual movement so they
were like it was about three young girls
who actually started messing with a
Ouija board and they would have knocks
and bangs and things would move and they
would actually demonstrate that work in
front of crowds for like you know 1,500
people 2,000 people back then what you
were talking about people would only
heard about from Milton Bradley right
back from the 80 I think I have one
mine's from 1984 actually yeah 1984 so I
think in some ways people
to use that as a tool I do believe a
Ouija board is a tool it has a bad rap
because of the background and what you
see in movies since I'm nature but if
you use it and open and close it the
right way it can be a tool I really
don't mess with it unless you know
people wanted to demonstrate physical
mediumship which is a whole nother level
where they actually produce like
physical where they allow channeling to
happen in spirits Epson and they
actually start channeling different
level ones and spirits like in a whole
nother level which is a whole nother
subject in itself has in spirit ever
showed up and started moving [ __ ] around
like telekinesis types no absolutely
absolutely am I've seen that in my own
house yeah stop [ __ ] around yeah my
parents again they're not big believers
in this work but my parents say they
would always say like take your friends
with you because every time I go I you
know I would go like people I would help
over to my house and you know I think
Moe has a great story I'm our maybehe me
take that one as well the best we have
brothers at Willie's house and he said
yeah he told Willie it really your house
the thing is haunted a couple stories
yeah we used to investigation back in
the day do you investigate the
Alexandria Hotel and I remember one time
we saw the spirit you know walking and
we both saw this little girl I'm like is
he seeing what I'm seeing and the little
girl actually died in the elevator shaft
we did not know that until afterwards
but that was one moment but I remember
at MoMA was at the house and he goes hey
do you see that black dog or do you have
a black dog here I'm like no but
everyone that came to our house would
always see this big black dog walk
around and that night people to actually
hear like click click click click click
walking on hardwood floors and people
would [ __ ] their pants and so people
would not want to see the night wouldn't
want to come over but I truly yeah I
truly live in absolute absolutely a
great you know a great example was I
remember reading his toy what I remember
I was reading for a lady in Virginia
Beach I think two years ago and I kept
on seeing Michael Jackson's monkey
bubbles and I'm like why am I seeing
bubbles while I'm seeing this what's the
reference and I'm like trying to pretend
I'm like did someone lose a monkey and
everyone in the audience is like
laughing they're like this is hilarious
and this way
she goes like I just lost my computer
compete you compete you yeah she just
lost her monkey about yeah lost her
monkey about me yeah to show it's
interesting so animals do come through
it shows their love but out of all
things like you would not expect like a
monkey to come through but I always tell
people like animals have unconditional
love they'll come through and value
those messages because of your fur baby
there's a personal connection but I love
what animals come through because there
is a personal connection that does come
through here yeah so talk to my hamster
[Laughter]
so are you do you see if there's
anything jump out at you well you know
there's two there's two things I feel
like and I don't know if you guys are
open to it but I think I I don't know if
I'm with either one of you guys but I
deaf people like I have an older
gentleman that is stepping forward here
I'd actually like this actually be more
of like an uncle figure rather than like
a grandfather figure that is passed over
there's also a reference I do neither
bring up for you guys either like like
Robert or Raymond or something like that
is connected here that is passed over so
is that connected to either one of you
guys here not on a Raymond or a robber
but Uncle Manny would he be like a
father figure towards you though yeah
okay I need to acknowledge us if that is
a case but there's also gonna be like a
Robert or like I like Robert Roger
there's a relearning that is connected
here that either still living or passed
over meaning if they're still living he
wants to say hello that person if
they're passed over that's who he's with
on the other side as well
I feel like when he comes through his
passing to me doesn't feel like it's
it's a quick passing at all whatsoever
it feels actually very lengthy when he
comes through because when he does talk
about his passing he's making like that
he's slowly deteriorating in some
essence that he's bringing up here and
there's also as a simplicity with him
that I thought as if I just like either
one took my last breath or either there
was either like some sort of quick like
emphysema thing that may have happened
here with him when he talks about this
does that make sense no okay okay just
make note to when I bring it up here if
that's not for you then I'm again I'm
yeah it could probably be from my theme
that's what I'm definitely with one of
you guys that is connected here just for
my film reference because again I think
there's two energies two male figures
that are coming through would there also
be like either like Joseph or like John
or Jonathan that's connected here that's
pastor so that Johnny okay is he passed
over yeah
okay.what also the month of December is
more to where the month of December we
connected to you okay so this would be
your dad's way coming forward then so I
need technology mind well that falls
over here okay so here's the thing do
you guys know each other or you guys
connected at all whatsoever know how you
know each other
okay I feel like these two male figures
are coming together so again if that
doesn't resonate with you I feel like
the either Robert the Raj of the our
name is also connected to you or to who
is your dad's with on the other side I
don't want you to think about it too
much but just hold on to it because
it'll be that moment that you're like oh
my god that's what it is that thing with
your dad when he comes through
he's mean like it's important to talk
about the family and talk about the kids
but I feel like it's more so related to
you or to the kids because your dad in a
very heavy heart he's apologizing
verbally and physically and he wants to
embrace you and saying I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry
it's not that he was a bad guy but I
feel like either he was geologically
away from you or either he couldn't be
around you as often if that makes any
sense okay I feel like when he comes
forward here he's identifying with you
that he's like living what he always
wanted to do in his own personal life
because his passing
doesn't feel like as it's like I pass
with a heart attack it doesn't feel like
that at all no but your dad don't but I
feel like when your dad comes through
there's a reference with him that makes
me feel like as if like I still died
young so I don't like he died in his 80s
or 90s I still feel fairly young with
your father when he comes through and
he's also making it like to acknowledge
either again who he's with or who he
wants technology but would there be a
Danny or David connected here either
still living or passive is my son my
brother okay can you say hello to him
and let him know that acknowledges him
because I feel like it's important to
validate and validate that love around
you guys do you mind if I do this okay
I really feel like that you I really so
I really put the reason why I think
you're surprised is that maybe perhaps
you did not expect him to come through
or maybe there wasn't again a personal
connection around that but I feel like
your dad needs to come through to
validate that love and validate that
connection with you in a very beautiful
way your dad's also bringing up my birth
month which is the month of April so
why's april connected here as well well
he died in April okay that's all you
know so this would be his way than
validating you and daddy not left to you
an amazing way the thing with your dad
though is that there's a unique
reference here is that what
he was a Jain aim though correct he yes
okay so I need to acknowledge them I
don't feel like that when I bring up dad
it feels different though so here's the
thing I don't know if there's also
another Jimmy James who's alive yeah
he's still living like a Jimmy or J my
brother is John gay as well so really
yeah I don't think that Jimmy story know
so no well James is Oh James is my
half-brother dad's some other son so yes
do you have any connection with him at
all whatsoever only on social media a
little bit can you please let him know
specifically that he wants to thank him
because I feel like they spent a lot of
time together or maybe perhaps he took
care of him at the moment of his passing
yeah okay because I feel like it's
important to him to recognize that
connection I'm still with my son that
thing with your dad though is that he's
coming through as a person that wants to
be funny he wants to come through with
the big smile and he wants you to smile
wants you to be happy but I really
believe it's because of what what we
talked about earlier how you and she
evolve and grow from this because I feel
like there's a lot of I want to say
baggage but there's a heavy energy
that's around you still that you haven't
emotionally detached or grieved through
because you're well aware that your dad
passed over but you haven't gone through
that grieving process of truly letting
him go and I think this is why he's
coming through to validate that
experience there's also a reference that
I may misinterpret this here and I got
again I don't mind being wrong but is
there any reason why your dad would
actually bring up like say his property
his land like did he owned a lot of land
in some ways he had a farm but he didn't
own it he had they had to give it there
to sell it back to the bank okay so
clear so after he does so I need
technology out if that is an issue that
may have happened here at this moment it
might just be his way identifying that
for you guys saying like don't worry
about dog dust your hands clean so if
that was an issue probably for James
okay please get that message to him or
please validate that again he may be a
big believer he may not be open to this
but I believe it's important why he's
recognizing you courtesy of the older
figure well that he comes through the
weird thing when yours dad comes through
there's a reference that I feel like I
need to bring up here and I may
misinterpret this but again I'm just
gonna give it to you was he you know I
want something so cliche when I say this
but I do want to say it did he actually
do some sort of unique like say even
though he had a farm there's something
about him like doing like engineering
contract
construction work there's something
about that I feel like as if I'm out in
the field doing this type of work in
some construction work okay I feel like
that your dad is still working but he's
retiring still on the side and doing
what he needs to do and I think this is
his way validating that love in a very
beautiful way Kent can I be very
personal here yeah the thing when your
dad comes through again he comes to it
with a heavy heart and I feel like it's
something that both of you guys need to
understand and make up and make an
agreement with because I feel like
whatever may have happened here I feel
like your dad saying like see the
language but he [ __ ] up I feel I guys
if he did not have enough time of
spending with you the family the kids
and things that nature and it feels like
it's it's way identifying that mom is
still living though correct yeah okay
okay was that it was that little too
personal or can you share that or okay
what happened in that moment were you
not around dad or what would that
situation my dad left us when I was 8
but it's because of my mom she was
abusive and so he started another family
years later which is James and my my
half-sister as well but I just recently
met them when he died two years ago but
but I he I forgave him for leaving
because I know now why he left but also
he you know he didn't have a lot of time
to parent us he was a great father to
the other kids and I discovered that
after I met them that he actually was a
great father and he never just you just
never got a chance with us I think this
is why I saying he effed up he
apologized for this because he couldn't
be in your life and do that fatherly
role in a very beautiful way and I feel
like with your dad's energy with the
kids or your step siblings or whatnot I
feel like it's important to recognize
them and bridge that connection any way
you can so if it's phone call text
social media whatever you use to make
that connection build that connection
and I feel like it's important to
recognize mom in that situation knowing
that I don't know if she understands
what she may cause or what she may have
done in that process but I just feel
like it's something that he wants to
it's yeah it's just something I thought
your dad wants to recognize that for you
the funny thing with your dad though is
that I I do want to say two things one
your dad is very humorous when he comes
through so again there's a sense of
humor that he wants to validate with you
but he comes to us someone being very
young and very attractive so he still
wants to let you know that he still
looks good as if he still has his hair
slicked back so I don't get a person
that has like crazy curly wavy hair I
feel like it's his way of validating
that for you and two there had been
something very unexpected that happened
here with their dad as a safer instant
your dad went in for like saying I don't
know
cardiovascular for heart problems and
often he found out that he had prostate
cancer I feel like it was a very sudden
illness that happened here that he talks
about here he had liver cancer but he
never went to the doctor so he didn't
find out until he was daughter he didn't
find out until he was terminal and he
only had like a month to live okay he
just was very quick very sudden how this
happened because he's me like whatever
happened here medical wise I don't feel
like I was able to get that obviously
that medical attention it was like heavy
like here right yeah yeah but it's more
so I think there's two things they [ __ ]
with your dad though ones an emotional
level that he gives to you make it
something that needs to happen here and
the other energies wants to validate
more so maybe his condition of how
things happened here but it the thing
with your dad it feels very very
prominent the way comes through but
there's a way with him as if he's still
in a way I won't say farming because you
set farming but I'm just gonna use a
worm farming that he'd love what he
loved to do basically because I really
believe that could have been a passion
or maybe that could have been something
that was just a work lively he really
wanted the farm okay it just just know
that I was doing the farm work based on
this side again for the information that
may not make sense here may be it may be
again his contemporary but there is a
Robert there is a Raymond there is that
connection that is passed over and I
would see this as then being your dad's
your dad's brother figure basically
because if he's coming through as an
uncle figure to you guys I would see me
as basically your dad's figure because
they come through to me as brothers not
as like a grandfather or father and son
but there's that vibration but it's on
your dad site not mom side and I feel
like there's also a reference that I do
want to bring up here what either like
the the the 30th or the 31st so it must
be significant to you well the 30th of
December is his birthday okay yeah so I
just know them the brother figure goes
to you so just make note of if it
doesn't resonate with you make note of
it because I feel like it's his way who
he's with could have been his
rather a very close friend his cousin
but it feels it's immediate so I don't
think it'll be a distant relative a
distant cousin but I think it's
important and two there is some sort of
emphysema or some sort of filling up
with fluids thing that is connected with
the smell as well when he brings us up
here so if it doesn't resonate no just
make note to it okay you good yeah yeah
mine yeah yeah that's crazy
great that's what's so fool bro you just
started going like when you started
going and it's like it's not like you
were thinking of it it's really just
talking when that just happens you know
you were on a flow it's not like you
were just going going going going going
going going
absolutely you're not in control of what
remember thirty days I don't know I
don't know that's why I said I don't
know if it's the 30th or 31st do the ask
you know they have 30 days I think some
November yeah would you ever miss killer
letter yeah because if that is the case
that could be its vibration coming
through saying it's around you it may be
that but if it's not that again years
I'm pretty good with dates of how they
come through you know if it seemed a
thing though but bill died remember
after bill died that's why bill died his
wife's sisters brother his sister's
husband I got my dad's sister's husband
okay that's why you know so it might be
his way stepping forward banking he had
us he smoked all the time but he had a
sudden heart attack okay yeah so that
might be his way coming through courtesy
of these guys again I honestly thought
again I don't mind me wrong but I
actually thought I was with them but if
it was these two males coming together
they come together as again brothers
basically how they come through so
that's the brother-in-law yeah so I
would just be their way coming he took
care of him he basically helped him buy
the farm okay okay that's one reason why
they would come together because a
personal connection there is that
relationship and just went in just one
last thing is there also like a share in
Shirley or the s name that's connected
here still living that we need
technology well my mother is sandy I'm
not sharing and Shh I'm trying to think
of his well you know it would make sense
for me but here's the thing she drank
sherry
it feels Charlene Manson you know and I
know you mentioned that they separate at
some point or they not talk or what if
that relationship is what she not still
involved with the husband or with your
dad at all like towards the end of his
passing oh yeah they hadn't seen me
forever the since he left no I just like
he wants to acknowledge her it's not
saying I love you I miss you but just
acknowledging her and that's all I want
to say because I don't want to say like
oh he loves mom he wants to give the
love to his wife away or whatever like
it's his way identifying that for you
know it's ya know there was no there was
a lot of fear fear around that yeah
that's all you know he was basically
didn't ever want to see her again and
your dad honestly in a way wants to
really say I love you he wants to give
that to you because I feel like verbally
he couldn't say that to you verbally he
wants to say I love you and give that
love to you in a very beautiful way yeah
thank you
what's up oh dear no right here bro who
me now in a great suit dine the Sheraton
resonate with you crazy no one now
dressed up but you know I think for you
guys to I think you guys are open and
receptive and either either if you guys
are believers or not I just want to
thank you guys and I respect you guys
for allowing me to be here honestly
because I own oh yeah no no it's super
cool because I think you're awesome
yeah I think you a believer with an
unbeliever
they said I not even watching other guys
said that you know whether I believe it
or not I like to see that Lisa got a
little closure yeah you know I'm gonna
look for a medium but I'm a large here's
the other thing is that everybody
listening might not be into it but my
fact it doesn't matter the message
wasn't for them right obviously
resonated with Lisa like yeah you just
reach out that wasn't that wasn't you
weren't talking to anybody but her and
that's the important part is that what's
funny and so that's what's I can put
there might be haters and might be right
[ __ ] them it doesn't matter the
the communication happen and you can't
take away what I just saw right now that
that was real as well what's odd is that
when you were saying stuff over here
about somebody over here
I started thinking oh no what if my dad
shows up I was like I was like I was
kind of relieved it was on them and then
it was starting to be my dad coming
through well I think it's important
because again whatever happened here
whatever your personal story is I think
it's important for you to recognize what
not from me but you what your dad easier
to say and how I need to come through to
validate you the family the kids all
that stuff because again is definite
James Coco is like Donny he's like no
not Johnny your brother that's another
person yeah my half-brother and I think
that's why because well obviously
because there is a personal connection
which he validated that he lived with
him or ray or whatever that is so
there's a personal connection but I
think you just said it perfectly like
you you know people are gonna hate
they're gonna discredit it they're gonna
find something wrong or I don't believe
it
you know okay with that because my job
is not to make anyone to believe around
here to kind of make things right but
whatever happens the moment is supposed
to happen for that individual that is
for you guys or if it's for Felipe or
free energy man like yeah it's the
energy and again I you said it earlier
he's like you know are you are you wrong
or can you be wrong and I again I'll be
first admit I can and will be wrong but
I will deliver the information that does
come through but I'm very blessed that
you guys allow me to be here and you
guys are open and receptive to this
whole process here again people when
your tour starts yeah I will start in
January they can find all the
information at which a bear calm on the
website under the events page or they
can sign up for my newsletter they get
monthly events or Instagram Instagram is
a Jay underscore Barrera and they can
find me all there as well all right man
take awesome guys thank you so much
Tamura no Martin Moreno calm crunch me
Morris Plains New Jersey on in January
and in Iowa for New Year's and Chicago
for the second of freakin January dude
it's it's an ex 2020 already board
not something crazy their food was
talking about bill bill bill and then
bill burr just came in thank you very
much everybody who came out to the show
tonight who listened to the podcast who
came out to a Spanish show last night
I'll see you guys in Napa and Seattle
this weekend don't forget to look out
for Martin Moreno Lisa right here with a
psychic reading the homie right here dog
hey tell us again your Instagram a che
underscore Barrera and other dilatory
men the Yemen podcast still going on
yeah and those podcasters have not the
in Spanish well that's what I got to do
that one yeah